We've talked before about the Kentucky Senate
race.
A longtime Republican senator and current
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell has
a real challenge in former Marine and Democratic
nominee Amy McGrath.
They recently debated and disgusting Mitch
McConnell just laughing, cackling when Amy
McGrath confronted him about his abject failures
in dealing with Corona virus.
He just laughs.
He's laughing as more than 200000 have died.
Take a look at this.
The House passed a bill in May and the Senate
went on vacation.
I mean, you just don't do that.
You negotiate.
Senator, it is a national crisis.
You know, that the Corona virus wasn't going
to end at the end of July.
We knew this.
I mean, I just think you've got to and here's
the thing.
If you want to call yourself a leader.
So will you.
You want to call yourself a leader.
You've got to get things done.
Those of us who served in the Marines don't
just point fingers.
And the other side when we get the job done.
Senator, you went on vacation when people
needed corona virus relief.
Quite a guy, right?
I mean, we we have to assume I really believe
in giving people the benefit of the doubt.
And I know there or every state has a lot
of ideological nutty right wingers.
We have to assume that not all Kentuckians
actually like Mitch McConnell, don't we?
In other words, part of why Mitch McConnell
has been in power for so long has to be that
many people simply aren't paying attention
and don't actually endorse this guy's complete
and total immorality.
I hope for the sake of humanity that that's
the case, at least to some extent.
Here's more of Mitch McConnell laughing off
accurate statements from Amy McGrath about
the Supreme Court, about corona virus relief,
about everything.
This montage includes part of the clip I showed
you just a couple of minutes ago.
And he's walking away from negotiations even
now when President Trump even wants negotiations
to happen before this election.
It's it's irresponsible.
Senator McConnell.
And instead of doing that, he is trying to
ram through a Supreme Court nominee right
now instead of negotiating.
Which is what he should have been doing all
summer long to make that happen.
Senator, you have an additional response.
We've got to get our democracy working because
we have to get through this crisis crisis
right now.
That's your time, Senator McConnell.
The Senate went on vacation.
I mean, you just don't do that.
You negotiate.
Senator, it is a national crisis.
You know that the Corona virus wasn't going
to end at the end of July.
You want to call yourself a leader.
You've got to get things done.
Those of us who served in the Marines don't
just point fingers and the other side and
we got the job done.
Is it all a joke to Mitch McConnell or or
does he at least see Amy McGrath as a joke?
Is that what it is?
Because that's the laugh of a hypocrite.
Unfortunately, there are many voters in Kentucky
who think at least he's not a Democrat and
they're going to vote for him.
That counts for a lot in many Republican stronghold.
Like Kentucky.
But imagine removing Mitch McConnell on November
3rd.
It's an uphill battle, no doubt.
But if you look at 538 ICOM, it says McConnell
has a 96 percent chance of being reelected.
The truth is, we don't have very recent polling
in Kentucky.
If you look at the polls on Real Clear Politics,
you'll see the latest poll is nearly a month
old.
Yes, McConnell was leading by 12 then, but
that was a month ago.
A lot has happened since then.
It could be six right now, within three weeks.
It could be less than six.
We just have no idea.
And it's a great race to get involved in.
And then briefly, just as a reminder, South
Carolina incumbent Republican Senator Lindsey
Graham has a serious challenge from Democratic
candidate Jamie Harrison.
Harrison has been raising ungodly amounts
of money lately.
But the concern is how much of the money is
from around the country rather than from voters
in South Carolina.
But the latest polls there are good for Harrison.
In the last month, the polls are a tie.
Lindsey Graham ahead by one and two more ties.
If you go beyond that, you're looking at polling
from July.
Very important race.
I think Harrison has more of a shot than McGrath.
But both really key races that you can get
yourself involved in.
Phone banking.
Door to door campaigning.
If you live in the states and you can do it
safely, et cetera.
Get involved.
And we are going to talk on today's bonus
show about some of these races and more as
well.
Get instant access to the bonus show by becoming
a member at join Pacman
dot com.
We'll see
you then.